fi o 3g wan buongiorno
con loro a salve
e veramente una coincidenza trovarmi qui
perché in realtà sono stato contattato
da andrea solo pochi giorni fa metto se
sei a bologna non puoi fare a meno di
passare altri ex è stata mi ha fatto
un'offerta che non potevo rifiutare come
dice il famoso film con un altro
siciliano bene quando mi ha contattato
né anni ha detto che il tema uno dei
termini questo tex era meraviglia
nell'oscurità
quindi si parla di oscurità e mi
meraviglia nella stessa nella stessa
frase e mi ha colpito molto credo che
l'astronauta ci sono molti punti di
collegamento in questo lo spazio un
luogo dove si fa innovazione credo che
teteks significa anche questo significa
innovazione per la mia definizione la
mia definizione di innovazione è una
strada in cui che tutti percorrono sono
tutti in fila a seguire i passi di chi
ci precede
poi c'è qualcuno spero che quel qualcuno
sia proprio tra queste file oggi che
vede questa strada e si volta da
un'altra parte
dove non c'è il cammino e sceglie
sceglie di fare il primo passo di quello
che diventerà un nuovo percorso dove li
dove non esiste questo è il significato
vero dell'esplorazione in questo senso
la mia presenza qui oggi giustificato
perché lo spazio è il luogo
dell'innovazione in tutti i sensi dalla
scienza la tecnologia poiché non lo
sapevo che sarei venuto oggi a parlare a
questo pubblico non ho preparato una
serie di slide non ho preparato un video
ho fatto una sola cosa ho scelto una
foto per parlarvi di meraviglia oscurità
foto
probabilmente o sito qualche nuovo nel
pubblico probabilmente molti
spero di no ma probabilmente alcuni di
voi hanno visto questa foto è una una
delle mie foto preferite da te sapere
che io non sono un fotografo non ho
molta esperienza non sono un tecnico
della fotografia mi sono un po giostrato
questo mio ruolo in orbita ho imparato a
utilizzare le macchine fotografiche
quindi questa foto da un punto di vista
della tecnica fare una foto scattata a
mano non è granché non è eccezionale non
sono un buon fotografo però c'è
qualcos'altro in questa foto che va al
di là della della tecnica e che invece
tocca altri argomenti
io vorrei cominciare dall oscurità
vi chiedo di vedere quello che non c'è
nella foto
guardatela bene cosa non c'è in questa
foto quello che non c'è sono i confini
questa è una foto che guarda l'europa o
parte dell'europa il mediterraneo
volando verso est
guardando verso ovest dalla stazione
spaziale internazionale
noi sappiamo che lì da qualche parte c'è
la francia da qualche parte c'è la
germania c'è la spagna il portogallo
io sfido chiunque a tracciare una linea
che distingua questi paesi è impossibile
è impossibile in questa foto ma non
perché siano sbiaditi o perché i pixel
non siano abbastanza netti e perché
queste linee non esistono e vi assicuro
che io l'ho visto con i miei occhi è
un'immagine molto più nitida di quella
che purtroppo vi presento nell'immagine
talmente nitida che fa parte della mia
memoria che ormai diventata è diventata
la mia storia
questi confini sono inesistenti guardate
guardate a ovest del dell'adriatico quel
quei paesi che nel secondo dopoguerra si
sono sbrindellati sono rimasti no sono
stati frantumati in tante diverse
andate a cercare quei paesi andate a
cercare quella divisione non c'è non
esiste questa è l'oscurità sono dei
confini e noi abbiamo inventato che noi
abbiamo creato con la nostra storia con
il nostro passato
io spero che adesso ci sia un momento
evolutivo la storia va va in avanti e
come un vento il nostro presidente a
repubblica ha detto delle parole
bellissime esiste il vento della storia
in questo momento in cui il vento è la
storia soffia fortissimo e cerca di
eliminare questi confini in un processo
unico che quello dell'europa
l'europa unita ed è per questo che io vi
parlo dello ster oscurità gli parlo
della meraviglia quello che si vede di
notte che supera nell'oscurità questa
luce nell opera dell'uomo di giorno
l'uomo sparisce dalla terra le terre
degli uomini sono sono restituite alla
loro forma naturale senza una volta
senza confini ma senza le opere
dell'uomo senza la sua presenza
ingombrante scomoda inquinante quindi è
bellissimo vedere la terra così come
sarebbe apparsa milioni di anni fa
senza questa senza questo questo forte
questa forte presenza
ecco di giorno e di notte invece l'uomo
si erge al di sopra di questa sua questo
suo essere umano meschino e ci presenta
con questa meraviglia perché vi assicuro
che vedere l'europa tutta illuminata di
notte e meraviglioso è una costellazione
più brillante di qualsiasi stella un
qualsiasi gruppo di stelle possedere in
cielo e non c'è soluzione di continuità
guardate e tutta unica con le grandi
città collegate dalle nostre autostrade
alle nostre strade i nostri mezzi di
comunicazione come una rete neurale
di un unico grande cervello un unico
grande organismo
questa è innovazione nel senso più più
ampio l'innovazione di una società
l'evoluzione dell'umanità verso un passo
futuro in cui riusciremo a lasciare
indietro le storie meschine di divisione
di sopra di sopraffazione lasceremo
indietro le nazionalismi lasceremo
indietro
l'idealismo l'ideale invece ci
soffermeremo sulle idee quelle sì che
sono importanti saremo tutti insieme
perché tutti insieme saremo più forti e
questo il nostro grande desiderio
dobbiamo fortemente desiderarlo di fare
questo salto evolutivo le generazioni
che ci guardano nel futuro sono già lì e
quindi il mio invito è di guardare
questa immagine vedere il potenziale
dell'uomo che è quello di di superare i
confini interni che sono quelli che ci
dividono gli unici confini che veramente
esistono e invece di super di guardare
ancora una volta con con sguardo
innovativo al di là della strada
tracciata verso l'orizzonte
quell'orizzonte e il futuro dove noi
stiamo andando
grazie grazie